hi I'm RIA I'm Alex hi guys I'm Catie
sup guys
I'm Alvin hi I'm Alexis time to get likk
oh yeah I'm going to add a little sugar
look at that I mean this lip cream looks
really pretty oh no oh no it's Sol yeah
let's make up theme songs Betsy and I
love to sing songs at work yeah
[Music]
like one song would be like gotta get
the bike shot gotta get that bite shot I
just dropped a bowl and my bowl Oh what
about the cheese oh the cheese ball
[Music]
beautiful stack it's like I got the
cheddar like in the rap music videos you
want to give it a name eggy
okay cute egg TV he's gonna hang out in
the water
eggy I served as well he has served as
well thank you for a sacrifice we arrest
in pieces I want to give it a name
before we cut it in half you're more
than welcome to
well let's name this after your middle
name which is Carl with
[Laughter]
[Music]
scanning each hen lays one egg every 26
hours so that means for one hen until a
100 eggs that would that would be damned
Asian I should be doing this better Wow
beautiful so now this is like a torture
device she taking this hair from other
people
yeah she's ripping hairs out okay okay
okay so I can try it yeah oh sorry
don't worry happy holidays
this is what I look like in every
holiday call me a turtle again just
looking at this I can see how the light
infomercial will come together are you
tired of like spilling stuff that's not
like a look at me it's like look at me
we ain't got no money for no marinade
this is da the dish I tried to make
Rogers visit Iman are you coming up I
got pow
now we're gonna add about 3 tablespoons
of butter and again if you put a little
bit extra ain't nothing to worry about
make you fancy Alvin Oh No
[Music]
don't forget to toss make it fancy thank
you for here make it fancy make it fancy
make it fuzzy make it fancy fancy make
it funky Oh
[Music]
[Music]